Gammage taka has to take every new shirt
to the tailor shop the sleeves vision
the red shirt is for reference it has
the correct cut he says taka was born
with deformed arms because during
pregnancy his mother took a sedative
called thalidomide thalidomide was sold
in West Germany from 1957 to 1961 under
the brand name contig on the deformities
it caused an unborn children became the
country's biggest ever pharmaceutical
scandal jacques mother was among the
pregnant women to receive the drug she
was supposed to get a sleeping pill or a
tranquilizer she didn't want it but she
was told it was harmless and that she
had to she couldn't refuse so she took
it when he was born no one recalled that
the connection wasn't obvious later she
remembered taking the drug America met
Muhammad a mosquito
it's hot move can put on her clothes
alone in the morning only if she's
wearing a dress
she's another thalidomide victim one of
2,400 in Germany when pitas mother first
laid eyes on her newborn baby she was
shocked
minam wata had done Kareem Dr Medina
says her mother started screaming her
arms her arms then she was immediately
tranquilized says the nurses took her
away afterwards she was presented
swaddled up and dressed like a little
package so that you couldn't see
anything she's done denied some of it
become me soon enough
oh and then her mother was put in a room
together with a woman who had miscarried
that's how things were handled back then
oh did estamos Ankush it's
I'm not controlling : when he goes
shopping gano shikaka always needs help
for years victims of the drug waged a
legal battle for increased state support
their demands were met only recently in
the form of higher monthly support
payments helpers therapy modified
apartments the costs add up fast
without a helper shikaka has often found
himself in awful predicaments
and the fregley has it websi 1 wah I was
at a meeting in a hotel he says I had to
go to the bathroom I managed to get my
underwear off and used the toilet but I
couldn't get my clothes back on and I
didn't have any help there i sat
helpless on the toilet after half an
hour someone came whom I could ask for
help that was unpleasant and degrading a
visit to the doctor but for God's sake
this isn't a personal appointment he's
in the process of building up a
countrywide doctors Network at present
there are very few physicians
experienced with physical deformities
into the feared and demoness mob most
doctors are puzzled by the special needs
of the widow my victims
shaaka says I broke my arm and went to
the hospital the doctor said it was
fractured but he said he didn't know
what it looked like before he had no
original pictures because my Anatomy is
different they don't know where to take
blood because they can't find the vein
or where to measure blood pressure
consider this once a week a therapist
visits Pete Oliver to massage her liver
spent half her childhood in hospitals
today she's 51 but has the body of an 80
year old that's common among the little
mite victims over decades their joints
endure heavy strain the therapist offers
what comfort she can do Pizza says her
left knee and left hip both hurt and her
right knee hurts more and more patella
VA's biggest worry is losing her
mobility and with it her ability to live
her own life
when she thinks about the future she
says it's horrible she says she can't
endure the thought she has to suppress
it and yet pittaluga has a job each
morning a transport service picks her up
she used to be able to walk she got her
driver's license at 18 and it gave her
independence
but for the last 15 years she's been
wheelchair-bound
her driving days are over
to swaggins for spa the condition was
awful she says I could still cry
thinking about it I still cry over my
car losing it meant losing my freedom
now I have to be belted in and wait I
can't decide myself when to drive away
earlier I just walk over to the car get
in and drive away
ganache taka can still drive but
important little aids like his phone
speech recognition software sometimes
fail the number please
same old thing he says the system isn't
working again doesn't recognize my
language socket needs to be mobile he
works for an IT company and he chairs
the Hamburg Help Center for thalidomide
victims he's certain that there are many
more people out there harmed by
thalidomide than have been officially
recognized some parents kept the
information from their children because
mother's felt guilty for taking the drug
and couldn't bear revealing the truth to
their children the parents have died
those children are making enquiries and
Cunha King is just such a case track is
visiting him today Cunha King asked for
help he was born in the early 60s and is
convinced that his foot is deformed
because his mother took the lid amide
yeah Tina Cunha king wants an official
recognition as it solidified victims
Chaka meets people like him all the time
okay he said a man stood at my table I
put my coffee down and
suddenly he started to cry no apparent
reason I said what's wrong
can I help he said you're a thalidomide
victim I said that's right but that's no
reason for you to cry he said he had a
daughter also at the lid of my baby she
only lived for six months
the man was over 80 this took place half
a century ago and he's still crying
about it hey Tom Nova is a social worker
at a Berlin hospital dan commissioned
pieces yet what's away
yeah
Sehun she says the work is good for her
and lets her help others and takes her
mind off her own problems but fears over
the future always return conferences
Yona she says I have no future plans the
way others plan their vacations in
advance and make arrangements
I can't think that far in the future I
don't know whether I'll still be able to
stand or whether I'll be in a nursing
home by then but they're both tenacious
people who refuse to succumb to their
difficulties they're also committed to
helping others jános taka is active in
an international network for people with
disorders of the limbs or dysmelia
good fine young man of Poland's actions
he tells us about a 26 year old man from
Poland born with dis Melia he lives at
home no arms no legs and he's not well
cared for
so she Takas Network is trying to do
what it can for instance seeing how he
can operate his computer using speech
recognition when he rides his motorcycle
Shaka can forget his disability and just
feel the freedom of the open road
you